[Music]
[Applause]
good afternoon
CSS Kampf my name is Elise and I work on
the front end core team at indeed comm
which is the world's number one job site
today I want to talk about our working
theory of modern web development
components but let's start with another
theory the law of gravity Newton's law
of universal gravitation states that
gravity a mysterious unexplained force
works on all objects in the universe
objects attract each other based on
their mass and distance more massive
objects attract each other with a
greater gravitational force and this is
what sends the planets in their great
orbits around the Sun newton's principia
mathematica was published in 1687 after
its publication the greatest
mathematical minds in Europe used
newton's law to discover and prove
truths about the celestial world
astronomers worked out sophisticated
descriptions of the orbits of the
planets called tables tables showed
where the planets should appear in the
sky and the calculations always matched
the real observations but over time
small discoveries begin to accumulate
that didn't make sense
the first observation of what would
later be known to us as the planet
Uranus didn't fit into the math some
planets like Jupiter seemed to be moving
faster in their orbits than in previous
observations and that couldn't be
reflected in the math many began to
wonder if Newton's laws were not
universal after all if there was a flaw
in the theory but not Orban Olivier
laverre ei was a French astronomer who
while not an excellent observer was an
unparalleled mathematician in 1846 he
posited that Neptune had to exist based
on the math of the orbit of Uranus Lavar
EA wrote to an astronomer here in Berlin
johann gottfried gala with the predicted
coordinates
and the very same night gala observed
Neptune within one degree of where
levare had predicted it should be in
response to claims that Newton was wrong
he wrote if the tables do not strictly
agree with the observations we will
certainly not be tempted into charging
the law of universal gravitation with
inadequacy in other words even if some
observations don't match the math we
shouldn't immediately say the entire
theory is wrong in Lovera Hayes eyes
there was no need to toss out gravity
altogether just because there were some
gaps in our knowledge at the time no one
even knew how gravity worked even though
the math made sense variable Eve this
time passed we would improve upon our
understanding over the past 20 years our
understanding of the world of front-end
development has changed
we've been iterating constantly on our
working theory of how to design and code
for the web it's fitting to talk about
this history at the tenth and last CSS
calm when CSS Zen garden came out in
2003 we were making web pages documents
the browser wars in the 90s had left us
with conflicting standards we
collectively fell in love with CSS and
then chain came jQuery and the
separation of concerns reusability with
CSS classes meant being able to change
our HTML without touching our CSS or
JavaScript as we began to build web apps
these complex interactive structures our
attention turned to tools that would
help us write more flexible code we
learned responsive web design sass
complex CSS architectures and new
JavaScript frameworks in the 2010s we
gained powerful tools like NPM web pack
and react on the design side we moved
from Photoshop to tools like sketch
abstract and figma they're slowly
narrowing the divide between design and
code we were looking for better tools
for reusability clarity and
maintainability we've used these tools
not just to create solutions to our
problems but also to create new to
fools these tools are changing the way
that we conceptualize our work we're
building on what we learned previously
and filling in the gaps and the unknowns
in the early 1850s levare was
calculating the orbits of every single
planet he intended to create a complete
set of tables that showed where the
planets would be in the sky at any given
time
first he mapped out the actual orbit of
the planet
based on calculations based on
observations next came calculations what
de Newton's laws predict the orbits
should be and the observations and the
calculations should match Venus Earth
and Mars were all correct one though
obstinately refused to conform mercury
Mercury's orbit shifts forward
incrementally each time as the planet
wheels around the Sun its orbit makes
its own gradual orbit creating a flower
petal effect the shift is too large to
be explained only by the pull of Venus
and Earth's gravity z-- levar EI and his
book length report on Mercury wrote that
the likeliest solution was a planet
between mercury and the Sun providing an
additional gravitational pull he named
this possible planet Vulcan Vulcan would
orbit so close to the Sun you wouldn't
be able to see it in the daytime and
like the Sun it wouldn't be in the sky
at night in the years after astronomers
all over the world observed Vulcan in
July of 1878 a total eclipse crossed
America's West from Montana to Texas
because the Sun would be obscured
getting a clear observation of Vulcan
was the biggest prize during the Eclipse
an American astronomer using a small
telescope a set up of cardboard circles
in a sharp pencil plotted the transit of
an object as it moved across the Sun he
and many others believed it was Vulcan
the math worked out it fit neatly into
the explanation of
Curry's orbit but over time observations
of Vulcan dwindled and people begin to
doubt that it existed for years the
question of Mercury's orbit created
discord between astronomers we know now
that Vulcan doesn't exist but people
kept discovering Vulcan because it fit
into their understanding of the world
the limitations of their tools and
knowledge at the time kept the answer
just out of reach as an industry we too
had a gap in our knowledge how do we
build firm maintainability and scale we
agreed that we're no longer building
pages we're building systems we agreed
that we need components that are
independent and reusable we agreed that
we need a single source of truth in code
for an easy authoring experience but how
based on our experience of the world
we tried varying solutions and tools for
some CSS tooling and methodologies for
others javascript CSS and j/s new ideas
are often criticized and dismissed CSS
and JS was controversial
it still is putting our CSS back in our
HTML was rejecting that separation of
concerns that we had learned in the past
you might build components for a web app
with a JavaScript framework maybe you
work on a component library or design
system maybe you use functional CSS or
assess and BEM or styled components
maybe use plain CSS and vanilla
JavaScript
maybe you feel stuck with your legacy
codebase your cardboard circles and
sharp pencils we're heads down in our
work trying to find solutions we're not
always thinking about the big picture
and this causes conflict among us as we
struggle forward to a better
understanding but we're still working
towards the same core idea so what is
our working theory of a component and
how can we solve for the values of
consistency cohesion reusability
authoring maintainability how do we test
this theory with the tools that we have
today we know that a component needs to
be three things it's easy to reason
about its if I context agnostic dry
independent and isolated first a
component must be easy to reason about
being easy to reason about isn't only
the amount of code or size or visual
complexity something that looks simple
can be deceptively complex and some
components that are hard to code are not
difficult to think about a component
that has too many variants will be more
likely to have bugs will be hard to test
if all the variants work or when they
get used you might have too many props
and options or different styles for the
component in different contexts on the
other hand too few options mean a
component is pointless there's a spot
that's just right where the component is
used for one or a few cases with enough
options to make it flexible complexity
in a component may come from design or
business requirements or it may build up
over time as developers add features or
designs change if your project is like
mine where many other teams use
components sometimes those teams needs
diverge at some point you may need to
split a component up into smaller pieces
that are easier to conceptualize if
there are common combinations you can
create shared parent components for
those four component libraries getting
other developers to use components
relies on their ability to understand
what the component is for often I see
developers say that they couldn't use a
component because it didn't offer the
right options that they needed sometimes
they're right but often they didn't
recognize the option was available a
component must have all of its options
and variants well documented in code
examples and tests so that's
discoverable and easy to understand so a
component that is easy to reason about
should be flexible enough to support its
use cases without being unwieldy or
confusing
second a component is context agnostic
components promised us reusability we
want to take a button or card or comment
block and use it all over our projects
to be reusable a component must be
context agnostic meaning it shouldn't
need to know where it is to look or
behave properly to function properly and
consistently across contexts a component
should not have logic that controls
functionality outside of itself it
should receive data down and send
actions up take for example a call to
action component it has a button when
the button is clicked a modal opens it
would be easy enough to write code that
pops a modal on click and that will work
until we want some other functionality
so instead the buttons should just
bubble up an event
I got clicked and the application can
determine what to do
when that event occurs styles for a
component should also have a single
source of truth whether you namespace
CSS with unique classes generate your
styles from JavaScript or use functional
CSS you know what belongs to the
component what does it and where to find
it don't rely on the markup structure
the contract between the parent markup
and the component to define the
component Styles the components should
have styles that are flexible enough
that it can live anywhere in a
full-width parent in a sidebar or on its
own and you can let parent components
control the layout like widths or grid
if a component is supposed to look or
behave differently in different context
make sure the logic behind those changes
is well-defined it's possible the
component needs to be split into two or
sometimes the best solution is not a
shared component at all but implementing
that feature as a one-off so a component
that is context agnostic will be
reusable and flexible
third a component is independent and
isolated to be context agnostic a
component must be independent and
isolated but isolation of functionality
and style gives us more than just the
flexibility to use a component anywhere
an independent component should have
good defaults like default text
accessibility settings and empty states
it should just work straight out of the
box this means it needs to import all of
its own dependencies we're familiar with
this pattern and JavaScript importing
packages as needed and this gives you
confidence in what is there and makes it
easy to test whether or not an imported
file is actually used a component being
independent and isolated means it will
look correct in an isolated environment
it cannot rely on the presence of styles
from a parent container or a global page
completely isolated components means you
also have the ability to test with
confidence you can generate each
component into its own page by itself
and run visual regression and unit tests
isolation for testing means that your
component tests only itself and doesn't
rely on other page functionality to work
properly we know then that any bugs we
catch in that isolated environment or in
the component and bugs elsewhere are
byproducts of how the application and
the components interact and this makes
us confident in the components quality
developers should trust that components
won't break their pages and it also
means we don't have to hobble the
creativity of our designers for the sake
of code predictability if you have
components that are understandable
independent and can live in any context
you can now use other components by
composition a component can import or
reference another component in its
markup it may make style tweaks past
props and change options data can be
changed in child components and events
and state passed backup and so this is
our current theory about the world of
modern web development
using the tools they had and what they
observed and the knowledge they had
Vulcan was the best explanation
astronomers in the 1800's had for
Mercury's orbit and it would take almost
60 years to add new information to the
theory it's 1913 and Einstein is working
on his theory of general relativity he
does a calculation to see what his math
predicts for the orbit of mercury and it
fits the core concept of general
relativity is that space and time can be
changed by the presence of matter a vast
mass like the Sun distorts space-time so
Mercury's orbit shifts because that's
the path that has to take through the
curved space-time around the Sun without
curved space-time you need some other
objects gravity to pull on Rectory with
curved space-time mercury is observed
orbit makes sense but Hine Stein didn't
disprove Newton's law of universal
gravitation gravity still exists the
tables of planetary orbits that lavera a
calculated in the 1850s are still
accurate
general relativity updated our
understanding of the world it filled in
some gaps gave us better measurements
and strengthened the theory that came
before many astronomers worked as
observers they saw and recorded how the
world really was others like the very a
and Einstein worked as mathematicians
pushing at the edges of our theoretical
knowledge and you get to do both you
might not feel like you can innovate if
you work for a big company or on an old
tech stack but the majority of us don't
get to use all the new cool technologies
I've worked on this theory of components
and everything from PHP and sass to
react and even plain CSS for Java
templates
even without the newest tools we are
applying this theory to our work your
project has limitations and constraints
the laws of the world we know what we
want components to be our theory so as
you write code how do you know if your
component fulfills the theory your
particular application of this
theory will depend on your particular
projects requirements and technical
constraints and indeed my team put
together a checklist that lives in our
projects contributing Docs and that
describes how we build components
defining what a component should be
gives you a tactical way to test your
results in the theory it outlines the
three high-level concepts I spoke about
being easy to reason about being context
diagnostic and being independent and
isolated but it also contains a much
more concrete list of what a component
must do here's some examples to be easy
to reason about a component must have
written design and usage documentation
as well as code comments for all props
options and variants it must have unit
and visual tests so we can make and
verify changes safely and it should have
limited variants that fulfill real use
cases with examples of how and when to
use them to be context diagnostic a
component must work in all supported
browsers and devices including touch
mouse keyboard and assistive devices it
should meet accessibility standards and
it should look and function correctly in
both left to right and right to left
languages it should have no external
layout properties like grid float or
even margins that would keep it from
being used in a variety of contexts and
it should receive data down from the
parent or page and bubble actions up to
ensure a component is independent and
isolated it must work in an isolated
environment it must define or import all
of its own dependencies including
JavaScript and styles and it should
define the component namespace or a key
selector only one time in one place it
should have appropriate default text
empty states and error States and it
should only affect itself and not rely
on other components or the page for
functionality this checklist makes it
easier for anyone who works on
components to do the right thing
with a checklist as a reference we can
be sure we've done everything necessary
to make a component that will work as
expected and be a valuable part of our
library we keep the theory
and promise of modern web development
close at hand and our everyday work as
we build code tests and try new
technologies we are observing how the
theory works and improving our
understanding
[Applause]
after formulating the theory of general
relativity Einstein pondered what would
happen when a huge object in space was
disturbed like two black holes colliding
he predicted that a cosmic event that
this disturbs the fabric of space-time
with enough force should produce ripples
in gravity scientists didn't agree many
believed that these ripples were just
artifacts of the new mass that somewhere
the calculations were wrong even if the
ripples were real they would be so small
by the time they got to us we wouldn't
be able to detect them anyway at the
time many scientists didn't even believe
black holes were real
this theory explained many things but it
also opened up new questions over the
last half-century there has been an
experimental quest to detect these
gravitational ripples that Einstein
predicted an international team of
scientists has built a pair of colossal
gravity wave detectors called LIGO to
try and detect these ripples LIGO the
laser interferometer gravitational-wave
Observatory took 50 years to build and
cost millions of dollars and the LIGO
teams weren't even sure they would
detect anything when it was done people
questioned doubted mocks them yet the
legal team is persistent because it is
crucial to think beyond today's
understanding of the world out in deep
space 1.3 billion years ago two black
holes circle each other churning up
space and time until they crash and
merge into one enormous black hole an
event outputting more than a trillion
times the power of a billion suns the
black holes collide in complete darkness
none of the energy exploding from the
collision comes out as light that energy
emanates as waves in the shape of
space-time as ripples in gravity an
astronaut floating nearby would see
nothing but the space around her would
ring
when black holes collide they make us
sound in December of 2015 almost exactly
a hundred years after Einstein presented
general relativity LIGO detected that
collision we heard two black holes
collide ligo's discovery verified
general relativity as fact and changed
the way that scientists understand the
universe
LIGO not only changed our working
knowledge of the world they accomplished
one of the greatest feats of modern
science and yet again we have new
questions to ponder our work may not
seem so grand what could be grander than
black holes planets celestial motion but
even firmly planted in our earthly work
we too can think like scientists
continually working to expand our theory
confirm it and strengthen it we build
new applications try new technologies
give conference talks create libraries
and design systems we are observing and
calculating what we learn will add to
our Theory help us create even better
tools and propel us forward into a new
world so as we work together today and
tomorrow and in the months and years to
come keep thinking beyond today's
understanding and on to tomorrow's thank
you
[Applause]
[Music]